hey guys so uh
this is interesting ever since i've been
given this show a lot of people have
been asking me what it's like they want
to know how i feel how do i feel a deal
who are these people
what's the deal with these people
ladies and gentlemen this is truly
exciting a comedy legend and good
comedian friend of mine sounds like he
just popped in he likes to come by the
show sometimes
to try out some of his untested jokes
so won't you help me in welcoming for
the first time to the pete holm show new
material seinfeld
hey hey how are you doing baby
hey new material how are you i'm not
doing great
not doing so good had a bad show tonight
yeah yeah you're working on some news
you're working on some new stuff that's
right
well why don't you uh you know we're
both comedians why don't you run some
material by me we'll see what's up pete
listen up here we go
got this new bit about pasta boxes
they always got that little window so
you can see the pasta
what does rigatoni need a room with a
view
i know what i'm buying
they don't do that with cereal you just
take cereal's word for it
rigatoni's untrustworthy or something
is that funny is that good
yeah i think that i think there's
something there the pasta has a room
with a view i like that good here's
another thing pets beds you got your
king bed you got your queen bed what are
we naming all the beds now
and why aren't that king and queen
sleeping together
trouble in paradise pete
cause yeah the king and queen are
married they should be together
i don't care for that don't don't riff
let me rip
how about the twin bed pete that's the
only bed you can't fit twins in cause
it's too small
the bed's too small
that's funny right yeah yeah it's too
small for twins the only bed how about
those overalls
do you ever see a pair of why do they
call it overalls they don't cover all of
you
they don't even cover your arms they
should be called over mosts
they're not even going near your
shoulders over subs
i think the guy that invented the
overalls didn't have arms to him they
were fine
that's good that's ready to go thank you
very much yeah that's right you're
holding
hold on new material
sorry it's a little uncomfortable down
here
i got a guy's arm jammed up my ass
and he is elbow deep
yeah
now who's riffing well
i'm not done with the overall thing oh
okay complete they got overalls over
they got underwear under what's in the
middle pete you got no clothing named
after the middle i want to know what
goes under the overalls but over the
underwear
that's good right is that funny
that is so close to real seinfeld stuff
i'm going to be honest with you pete i
don't feel good about this material i'm
willing to give you 50 bucks for that
baby names routine
new materials
you